whenever I'm struggling with
procrastination or what I think is
procrastination the first step is to
actually just stick the thing in the
schedule and figure out what
specifically the next action step
actually is good and there's other
research to show that when we think
about things in the abstract they seem
to belong to Tomorrow there's no sense
of urgency to them and when we think
about things concretely there they
belong to today so you put those two
things together and it says something
about the way the human mind works that
we can well in a sense we can borrow
this notion of nudge right that we we
move ourselves in the direction of the
way the mind works by saying I'm going
to set a time and a specific behavior
I'm going to make it as concrete as
possible because concrete goals my brain
treats them differently implementation
intentions also help us break habits or
establish new habits because we put the
cue for the action into the environment
and not rely on internal cues because
internal cues I've already got my habits
established